Based on a true story,
my heinie!
This year's Oscar movies
are riddled with inaccuracies.
Am I the only one
with standards?
Is Brian Williams
writing all these scripts?
I wish Hollywood had
half the integrity of Tosh.0.
And when I found out
how easy it is
to get into these press junkets
if you have a TV show,
I decided to confront
some of the biggest celebrities
face-to-face about all the fibs
in their films.
The thing is, you only get
2 minutes with each person.
Okay, Angie, this movie
was a giant lie
from start to finish.
You know,
I think that's--
You left out the part
where he shook hands
with Adolf Hitler
after the 1936 games.
And you kind of
glossed over the fact
that he was an alcoholic
who verbally abused his wife
and didn't find God
until right before he died.
Why are you a terrible director?
Oh, 'cause
I don't have...
that skill.
We agree on something.
Next!
Huh.
Took some casting
liberties, I see.
I'm curious why the movie
would leave out the fact
that your mom
was happily remarried.
Um...
And there was basically
a whole community of people
hiking the PCT.
You were seldom alone
on that trail.
Liar!
Next!
Oh, Cumberbatch,
where do I begin?
He knew German,
he never called his
computer Christopher,
and he was openly gay
the whole time
and constantly
hit on dudes
whether they
were gay or not.
Oh, and Keira Knightley
did not get a job by
solving a crossword puzzle.
So stupid.
Next!
[haltingly]
Very nice to meet you, Stephen.
I'm just kidding.
How come you
left out the part
where the sexy nurse you
cheated on your wife with
abused you
for over five years?
Oh!
And you told Jane
you had ALS
before you
started dating,
your friend Brian
never existed,
and you're the one
who decided
to get the tracheotomy,
not Jane.
Also, I noticed
one of your formulas
was wrong on the blackboard
in the movie.
You're being awfully quiet.
I guess if you fist-[bleep]
me, we'll be even.
Next!
Let's start with the fact
that the real wrestler
this movie's about
tweeted
"Hate it. Hate it. Hate it.
"Hate it.
Sue me all you want.
My integrity is worth more
than this bull[bleep] story."
Yeah, all of those things.
Why did they make
your nose bigger?
The character
you were playing
had a smaller nose
than your real nose.
The real mystery
is why they left out
how du Pont was a
paranoid schizophrenic
who searched for Nazis
on his property
and talked to rocks.
[sighs]
What the [bleep], Steve?
Well, I--as you said,
I think there
was an added element
of--what's the word
I'm looking for?
Horse[bleep]?
That's probably it, yeah.
Next!
Sure, for the record,
Chris Kyle didn't kill Mustafa.
He heard other snipers did.
Stolen valor.
And I don't care
that he claims
he was perched on top
of the Superdome after Katrina
to gun down 30 black looters
in cold blood
or that they left out the fact
that Jesse "The Body" Ventura
successfully sued him
for $2 million
for defamation of character.
He's a goddamn hero,
and if you don't
believe and support
every word of this movie,
you are a threat
to our national security
and a terrorist.
And for what it's worth,
I thought your performance
was breathtaking.
I know we ignored Selma,
but so did the Oscars.
And if you need more proof
that the Oscars
are completely out of touch,
there was not one nomination
for the real best film of 2014--
Yeah, John Wick.
Did you see it?
Watch it!
The guy's got
way more confirmed kills
than that American sniper.
I dare you to call John Wick
a coward.
Shame on you, the Academy.
Shame.